second image very quickly is a
photograph
of Helena Carter Helen is a friend and I
love her I wrote to her when I was 14
15. having read this book and I sent it
to Helen the Bonham Carter there were
all these characters and I thought oh
well Helena could play that such and
such could play this and then there's
this young lad who's gonna play that and
then I just left a picture of my face
and my very short CV which was like
doing The Wizard of Oz in year six that
was on the final page so the idea being
that she'd finish the book and she'd go
but this is great but who's going to
play the young lad I don't think she did
I know she didn't because I've since
become a friend of hers but she sent me
that note and I've kept ever since it
says Dear Josh thank you for the book
good luck Hannah Blanc Carter this is